breaking news tonight surrounding sites
apps like this all across the valley
Governor Joe Lombardo declaring a state
of emergency after a gas leak in
California has led to fears of a
shortage all over Southern Nevada the
governor releasing a statement which
says in part tonight I am declaring a
state of emergency for the fuel pipeline
leak impacting Southern Nevada this
emergency declaration will allow us to
receive federal waivers and resources as
we navigate the evolving repair timeline
so this is actually the pipeline that
the governor is talking about this is
the Kinder Morgan pipeline it's located
in Long Beach California it is one of
two that serve our Valley with fuel our
8 news now investigators have discovered
a filing from the company indicates that
the leak was first discovered yesterday
and they do have that leak now contained
in response Clark County has declared a
fueled emergency of their own which says
in part in coordination with Governor
Lombardo Clark County has issued an
emergency declaration to allow for
additional resources it went on to say
this leak has not impacted the supply of
fuel but rather the method in which this
fuel normally comes into Southern Nevada